some people think i did something i
don't even think i [ __ ] started
hello everyone and welcome to the first
episode of wine library tv i am very
proud to launch what we think is the
first video wine blog we feel like we've
got something very special here when
people go back and watch the first
episode of wine library tv i was 31
years old i
asked somebody on my team to run to best
buy pick up a little cannon camera set
it up pick three bottles of wine i put
them on a table i filmed it first time
i've ever filmed anything with the
purpose of anybody seeing it two years
into wine library tv and nobody gave a
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] but i didn't want to give
up welcome welcome welcome to the
askgaryvee show trash talk to be friends
there is no [ __ ] system there's no
[ __ ] shortcut it's a [ __ ] marathon
it's hard
it takes time love the journey because
if you don't love the journey you'll
never get through the first quarter
we're gonna get better we're gonna keep
pushing it and we're gonna try to do
something that is different